the Democrats will lose control of the
House of Representatives in January but
the party was in jubilant mood as it
convened in the chamber on Thursday
the house will be in order
after days of speculation Nancy Pelosi
the first female Speaker of the House
confirmed that she will be stepping down
from her leadership position in the
party a position she's held since 2003
and with great confidence in our caucus
I will not seek re-election to
Democratic Leadership in the next
Congress
for me the hours come for a new
generation to lead the Democratic caucus
that I so deeply respect and I'm
grateful that so many are ready and
willing to shoulder this awesome
responsibility
she was received raptorsly by her caucus
a show of unity and stark contrast to a
Republican party in turmoil after a poor
sharing in the midterms they may have
won the house but their majority is very
narrow
the Republican Party establishment
blames the Donald Trump wing of the
party for the midterm election results
but the Trump wing of the party blames
the Republican Party establishment for
not being bold enough and going after
the Biden Administration
with the majority in the house the
Republicans can launch Congressional
investigations into the Biden
Administration already they say they
will be looking into Joe Biden's son
Hunters business dealings and
allegations of corruption involving the
president this is an investigation of
Joe Biden the president of the United
States and why he lied to the American
people about his knowledge and
participation in his family's
international business schemes
National Security interests require the
Committee conduct investigation and we
will pursue all avenues avenues that
have long been ignored but the current
Republican leadership is wrestling with
how far it should go to appease the
Trump wing of the party without
alienating swing voters ahead of the
next elections in 2024 she had returned
to see Al Jazeera Washington